und in athen für uns meine kollegin
liana spyropoulos of you videos ein
resort control top 100 europe
feinmotorik
ich habe jetzt gerade noch mal gefragt
ob die kontrollen dann tatsächlich so
streng sind wir kennen es ja hier aus
deutschland dass manche maßnahme einfach
nicht umgesetzt werden könnten aber
meine kollegin hat gesagt er stimmt man
braucht diese sms wenn man draußen sein
welche die polizei kontrolliert viele
menschen auch in den autos und die die
auf der straße sind so relaxt
das ist nur ein abonnement oder
pavillons hat los
fraglos familie mit was bedeuten diese
strengen kontrollen jetzt also für die
menschen wie es die stimmung im ganzen
land und da berichtet meine kollegin
dass die stimmung ziemlich deprimierend
ist denn die menschen sind es gewohnt
draußen zu sein mit freunden sich zu
treffen cafés restaurants alles dazu man
darf auch niemanden mehr treffen und das
merkt man jetzt ganz besonders mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren